I have a question for Ewa Zajczkowska
Hernix confederation
You tweeted about our debate.
that is led by Monika Olejnik herself
say I'm entering a nest of leftist wasps
It's like saying nothing.
What Did You Mean When You Talked About Us
EE even this
as the only one in the first round
I did not receive any questions related to the economy.
with EE taxes
Inflation and the Economic Situation
em and so on and so on
with the viewer affair
The situation of farmers
EE I was convinced and I was not surprised at all
Eh,
because that's exactly what happened.
I was the only one
EE a purely worldview question and Once again
They were simply
you drew controversial statements
hm janusz korwinicki
which already has a function in our party exclusively
Honorable so yy
this is your way of grilling the confederation
We are the biggest threat to you.
and you know it very well
The Confederation is the only party
is an extra-systemic party
This is why we are going to the Sejm just to break this system
I'm out of the leftist show
yy sld psl and so on and so on
because it is 1 click
who has ruled us for 30 years
That is why they attack us in this way.
and that is why they draw
some random statements
just to embarrass us in your eyes
do not give up